Is it true that if the acidophils are over three, it means the presence of a parasite?
No, so
elevated the acidophils. Can that be parasitic? It can be. Can that be an allergic reaction like from pollen? It can be
a member
It's not specific solely to one thing. It gives you clues. Every lab you do
it gives you clues. And so if a person has elevated white blood cells and elevated the acidophils you'd want to match that with
their history
and to get an idea if they have a history of no allergies whatsoever and they have a history of current
got issues that you could take. Well, maybe we should treat for parasites
But they have a history of no got issues and they have a history of a lot of
hyper allergies and environmental toxicity issues. Then you think that it's probably from the
environmental issues and allergies and you may treat completely different. So you
use blood work in ways that it's giving you information. It's giving you data. It's giving you
objective information to guide you along your treatment plan
Just like in the last question. Oh, I have elevated DNA circulated to ourselves
Well, does that should we change our whole protocol? Should we now go on chemo?
No, that doesn't really tell us any data. It gives us maybe a little bit of a clue
But it's so minor that I wouldn't spend the money on that test
To do any acidophil test in a CBC with a differential that's going to give you a white blood cell count
And a differential and the different types of white blood cell code is very inexpensive
And it gives you more data on how to treat the patient
So that would be a better test not necessarily cancer but for whatever is going on
So again, you use lab work to give you clues
On what's going on so that you can best treat with the patient as objectively as possible